[Musique]
en finale de la coupe canning de
football l'équipe des dogues rencontre
celle des bulldogs
d'entrée la partie et acharné et le jeu
de tête est à l'honneur ce héros gardien
de but mais d'or aux x internationale
est aux aguets car sur une passe de kiki
à l'ego tabarand bientôt centre sur
hazard est le but des dogues est menacée
mais le gardien de but dégage en touche
alors mise en jeu une magnifique
combinaison des dogues ne s'amorce au
centre du terrain et sur le museau
remarquable d'azor c'est un nouveau but
les deux semaines par trois buts à 1 à
la mi temps
à la reprise la partie sensationnelle
mais dans des gages bobillot pente qui
intercepte passe en or qui dit surin de
tain mais fifille repensant tour est
passé mais mr coup franc pour les bus
donne un point de la partie et émouvante
trois fois de suite mais d'or renvoient
la balle est finalement les deux gagnent
par 7 buts à 3
[Musique]